y vencedor of aparecía en estas imágenes
la semana pasada poco antes de que lo
capturaran las tropas rusas el viernes
11 de marzo
el alcalde de melito paul fue el
liberado finalmente este miércoles y
posteriormente mantuvo una conversación
telefónica con el presidente ucraniano
estoy realmente muy feliz de escucharte
tu voz es la de un hombre vivo gracias
muchas gracias por no darme abandonado
nosotros no abandonamos a los nuestros
kiev anunció este jueves que consiguió
la libertad de fedeoro a cambio de
devolver a moscú nueve soldados rusos
prisioneros de guerra
el alcalde de 33 años había sido acusado
de terrorismo por los rusos que ya
ocupan la ciudad que gobernaba en la
región de zamorilla en el sureste de
ucrania tras la captura las tropas rusas
lo habían llevado a la región
separatista de lugansk y en melitópol
fue reemplazado por esta mujer galina
denisenko su principal opositora pero
tras la captura del alcalde la población
de melitópol multiplicó las protestas
contra las fuerzas de ocupación rusas
domingo y even matter el alcalde de la
ciudad de ny produce a 80 kilómetros de
también fue tomado como prisionero por
las tropas rusas de momento no se conoce
su paradero